pues hay que tener en cuenta el inmenso
valor histórico y también simbólico que
tiene nagorno karabaj para los armenios
hasta el punto que la posible pérdida de
siquiera una parte del territorio de
nagorno karabaj es para ellos el
capítulo cero de un nuevo genocidio como
el que sufrieron a principios del siglo
20 hay que recordar que armenia tenía no
sólo el control de nagorno karabakh sino
también de algunas zonas que
técnicamente no son nagorno karabaj
zonas cercanas que sí que son territorio
azerbaiyano pero que lo había ocupado
hace años para poder defenderse mejor y
ahora se va a dar la situación contraria
va a ser azerbaiyán la que va a tener
parte de esos territorios de nagorno
karabaj e incluso algunos muy
importantes desde el punto de vista de
la población porque esa es una ciudad
muy importante pero también desde el
punto de vista estratégico de cara al
futuro porque desde ahí desde ese punto
elevado va a ser mucho más fácil volver
a atacar en el futuro para conquistar
más porción de nagorno karabaj y
quitarse la armenia xavier hablemos
ahora el papel que jugó rusia para
lograr este acuerdo de paz y que tan
firme es este pacto
pues rusia vuelve a ser una vez más el
árbitro de los conflictos en su
vecindario rusia va a desplegar tropas
que van a velar por la paz y también por
la movilidad dentro de esa zona tan
convulsa era aunque también quería hacer
turquía que aspira a tener a través de
él de su aliado azerbaiyán un mando en
plaza en esa zona pero no se ha existido
hoy esta mañana que cualquier
declaración que apunte a que va a haber
fuerzas turcas en la zona es falsa
porque eso no forma parte del acuerdo y
por otro lado consigue que ni azerbaiyán
y armenia
consigan una victoria total puesto que
es rusia es de alguna manera aliado de
armenia pero también proveedor de armas
de azerbaiyán así que rusia sigue siendo
el árbitro y el que manda